ladies and gentlemen I've always wanted
to have a paper that is so short it can
fit in one or two pages because then
when you print it your paper is actually
just one paper
and to get us such a paper what you need
is a result which is interesting so it
can be published somewhere but you also
need an extremely clean proof of that
result that can fit in two pages and I'm
very happy to say that this result that
I'm going to talk about today is exactly
such a result
we have a paper that is actually longer
than two pages but that's because we
wanted to have like a complete paper
with introductions and decent coverage
but if we wanted we could have actually
just published this paper as one paper
with the result and the proof in it
so let's see this the result is about
streaming algorithms for Boolean csps
and I will start by defining constraint
satisfaction problems or csps
I will Define these problems using this
Sudoku puzzle that is very famous the
point is you have a nine times nine grid
of cells which each cell having a number
between one and nine some of these
numbers are there already and in the
blank cells you have to insert a number
between one and nine such that each row
each column and each three times three
Square
is all unique numbers between 1 and 9.
in other words each row each column and
each three times three square is a
permutation or has distinct numbers
between 1 and 9. and the reason this is
a CSP is because you can look at all of
these blanks as variables let's say you
have n variables
you can have one constraint function f
that captures the fact that it takes
nine arguments and it captures the fact
that all the nine arguments are distinct
and you can Define Clauses using that
function so one Clause Is For example F
applied to this set of nine variables in
this column and you can also apply after
this row you can apply after this prayer
you have many Clauses like this and you
can write this pseudo2 puzzle as the set
of clauses
and a solution to the Sudoku puzzle is
just an assignment to these blanks or
the variables that satisfy all of these
Clauses of course some of these are fits
so some of the Clauses have fixed
transcends in them
this is a CSP but it's actually slightly
different from what we will use in our
paper our csps will not take values over
nine it will just be Boolean so the
values are 0 1. and moreover we will not
be interested in finding an assignment
that satisfies all the Clauses instead
we shall try to see what is the maximum
number of Clauses that can be satisfied
by Any Given assignment
so two differences one is Boolean so of
course you have a variable as complement
and second difference is instead of
finding an assignment that satisfies all
the Clauses you want to find the maximum
number of Clauses that can be satisfied
by any assignment
we want to do this using a streaming
algorithm which basically is an
algorithm that gets as input a sequence
of all the constraints so you have these
three uh
you have to row constraints you have
these column constraints these are
presented at the algorithm in some
arbitrary burst case order and the
algorithm gets to make p passes for a
parameter p over this sequence of
constraints
now we want our algorithm to have low
memory because we don't want the
algorithm to just remember the entire
sequence we want it to actually make all
these passes and then compute such
output and we want to know what is the
smallest amount of memory or the
smallest space usage that is streaming
algorithm with P passes can have so
you'll always think of p as
let's say logarithmet in the number of
variables so it is not very big um and
we want to know what is the smallest
amount of memory that an algorithm with
P passes can have and find out exactly
the number of Clauses the maximum number
of Clauses that can be satisfied by any
assignment
this is the problem
and it's a natural problem so there's a
lot of work on it and one thing that we
know is that for all non-trivial
functions F non-trivial meaning
for example it's not the function that
is always one so it's always
satisfactory anything that is not
trivial in that sense you need
memory and you want to know the answer
exactly you need memory that is at least
Omega n over P again p is logged in so
this is basically Omega n for the exact
solution
we do not know whether or not this is
tied
but we do know that if you relax this
requirement to a one-man reception
approximation you still need almost
linear space you need enter the one
minus Epsilon space
if your function f is the match start
function for other functions we do not
know
this is what we know and there has been
other work on csts that I have not
covered in this table but the reason is
all of this other word it focused on
getting the right approximation Factor
it restricted attention to single pass
algorithms and it wanted to know for
each cspf what is the exact
approximation Factor above which it is
hard and Below which it is easy
we take a different direction we instead
want to work with multi-pass algorithms
we want to work with P pass algorithms
and we want to know exactly remember
this is not type we want to know exactly
what is the amount of memory or space
required for such an algorithm to solve
CSP
exactly and approximately
this is what a result is about we want
to show tight space bounds for
multi-pass algorithms and we show a
result for each of those two lines
for again for all p and all non-trivial
F where non-trivial means something here
it also means something precise here
um
for Exact Solutions if you have a p pass
algorithm then you basically need n to
the degree of f space where degree of f
is the degree of
the function f when it is written as a
multilinear polynomial over the reals
for example if you have the function and
of two variables then the polynomial
will be x 1 times X2 and therefore the
degree will be 2. you can do this for
any function and we show that for any p
and for any non trivial F the space
required to solve CSP for f exactly is n
to the degree of f
this is for Exact Solutions for
approximate solutions for one minus
Epsilon approximate Solutions we had a
result format start and we showed that
that result actually it sends to all
non-trivial csps if you have any
non-trivial space cspf and you have a p
pass algorithm then you need almost
linear n to the one minus Epsilon space
to approximate it within 1 minus Epsilon
these are the two results they complete
the picture and I will only talk about
the proof of one of these results most
of the ideas actually it's sent to the
other one so it is actually like it is
easy to just focus on this result and
the other one will be very similar and I
will prove this in two steps
I want to prove that for any function f
any streaming algorithm with P passes
for map cspf dates into the database
space
and
to do this let us first see what where
is this enter the degree coming from why
is this degree term appearing in this
theorem and for this let us try to
understand some approaches for solving
this function f
data function f let's say it has Cable
in variables and it has a Boolean output
and first note that because you only
have three different variables the
number of different constraints that you
can have in your CSP is only into the k
so you can actually capture the entire
instance by taping into their K counters
one for each different type of
constraint and just seeing how many
times it appears in the sequence
maintaining this many counter States
into the test space and with this space
you have the entire sequence so you can
compute anything you can solve the
problem exactly
now this bound is clearly not tight
because
what may happen is for example you have
K variables in F but actually it is just
a function of one variable the other
variables are just placeholders
and by this exact argument we know that
the space required for such a function
is actually not K it's actually n to the
K it's actually much smaller
and
therefore something better is possible
but exactly how better
I claim that again if you write f as a
multilinear polynomial over the reals
and you see its degree then you have a
solution that dates enter the degree
space why
every time you see a clause let's say a
clause is X1 and X2 and X5
you instead of regarding this Clause you
record the corresponding polynomial so
here the polynomial will be X1 times
because of the negation one minus H2
times x five
this polynomial will have degree degree
of f let's say 3 here
um therefore it has at most enter the
degree of f different monomials and you
can record this polynomial by using only
n to the degree of f counters this again
has all the information that F has this
remembers the entire instance and
therefore by using enter the degree of f
counters you can solve it exactly and
this is a better solution
it's not really much better though for
many functions for example if f is and
then degree of f is J so these are
actually the same solution it's not that
better can we do something that is much
better than end to the degree or into
the k
and our result shows that actually no
this enter the degree of solution which
is enter the degree of f solution which
is so easy is actually tight you cannot
do anything better even with P passes
and the argument for this is two steps
first you show that
if first you assume that you cannot do
anything better for the function f
equals and and you show that this
implies you cannot do anything better
for any function and the second part is
that you actually show your assumption
show the lower Bound for the and
function
and we will take those things separately
so for the first one I want to show that
any function f reduces to the and of
arity degree of f and for this I have to
show that if you have an algorithm for
Max cspf for any function f then that
algorithm will also solve maths and F
where the RT of and is equal to the
degree of f
to show this it is sufficient to show
that you can write the and of let's say
two variables this will be approved by
example so I will work with only end of
irk2 and of two variables as a set of
Clauses for any function or even any
polynomial that has degree to
how do we do that suppose you want to
write the end of two variables you want
to write X on x2 and you are given this
weird polynomial that is not exponent H2
I claim that you can still write and of
x 1 x 2 which is X1 times H2 using just
this polynomial
the way you do this is
you write this polynomial twice so you
get 2 times P of x 1 and X2 this is 12 x
1 x 2 minus 4 x 1.
and you also write a corresponding
constraint with H2 set to the fits value
1.
the value of this polynomial is actually
just 6x1 minus 2 x 1 which is 4 x 1. and
therefore the sum is 12 x 1 x 2 minus
4x1 plus 4 x 1 which is equal to 12x1x2
and what you are able to do whatever you
were able to get here is you were able
to write this and function as just the P
using just the three p Clauses P of x 1
x 2 twice and P of x 1 comma 1 1.
this means that if if you have an
algorithm for p then you also have an
algorithm for and and therefore it can
reduce to one
for General functions P or polynomial
speed we have the same high level idea
we have one high degree term that we
want to keep and we want to eliminate
all the loaded returns
here we are lucky because we are just
have to add tx1 comma 1 but in general
you may have to subtract it you may have
more constant weights here but all of
that can be done because if say if you
want to subtract something you just
write x one bar and that makes the sign
different and again you will be
subtracted while actually having a plus
here so you can write a sequence of
Peace that's that eventually you'd
attend and this is why you can reduce
any function f to add after degree of f
variables and this is the first step in
the proof
the second step in the proof is to
actually show a lower Bound for Rand we
want to show that if you have an and
function of K variables then you need
enter the case space for it and in fact
we will show it for the or function it's
the same proof of word for n but it will
be easier to work with or here and the
way we will show this is by showing that
this jointness can be reduced to this R
problem
we know that designers requires High
communication so it's also hard in
streaming and once we have this
reduction we also get that the or
function is hard is streaming
what we need to show is we need to take
a disjoint instance which is defined by
Universe U Alice has a set that is
contained in you Bob has a set T that is
contained in you and they want to know
whether or not the sets SNT are disjoint
or are they intersecting
We Know by standard lower bonds for
disjointness that
the communication required or the memory
required for streaming algorithm to
solve disjointness
is actually just the size of you
even if you're promised that either SNT
are disjoint or they intersect in
exactly one set
this is the lower bond that we shall use
and for the reduction I will show that
if you have an algorithm that solves a
CSP for r on N variables then you can
use it to solve disjointness on case I
subsets of n the size of this universe
is entered the case so yet you are into
the tail lower bound and the reduction
is the following simple
um set of steps first Alice States her
set of K side subsets of n
and for each case size subset of n that
is not in her set she adds the r of
those variables
Bob does the same these are some Clauses
that you can add and if you look at
these carefully these Clauses basically
want as many variables we want as
possible as soon as your variables are
one more and more Clauses like this are
satisfied and
if all of them are run then all of these
are satisfied
the other set of Clauses that you add
you will actually want variables to be
zero and this set is just you want to
add H PSI bar for all I and M this is
the same variable K times so it's
actually just at PSI bar and this
basically means all variables should be
pushed towards zero for these Clauses to
be satisfied
now
why does this reduction work
the reason this works is you have this
force that is pushing all the variables
to be higher towards one you have this
Force that's pushing all of these
variables to be lower towards zero
the first force is actually much higher
much stronger than the second one
because this has all subsets of size K
this has n to the K potential
possibilities and this only has n so
this force is actually much much
stronger and your default solution would
be to set
all but K minus one of the variables to
be one and those T minus 1 will be zero
what this will achieve is anything that
has K constraints will have at least one
thing that is one because there only K
minus one thing zero zero so everything
like this will be satisfied and also K
minus one of these will be satisfied
which is the largest possible because
you want this Force you know this force
is stronger so you want you first want
to maximize this and then you want to
maximize this
okay this is the default case but
observe what happens if Alice and Bob
actually have an interception if there's
a set s that is in both the sets then
because it's in both Alice and Bob sets
none of them added the clause or
corresponding to that one set
and that means you can actually set K
variables to be zero which is all the
variables in that set
and this will still satisfy everything
here
but now it satisfies one extra thing
here
and determining whether or not this one
extra thing can be satisfied is exactly
solving whether SRT are intersecting in
one location or are they disjoint
this we can write it out we can write
out the numbers it will exactly be this
one extra thing is the answer of this
jointness and therefore
a CSP algorithm for R can also be used
to solve this jointness on this universe
and therefore it needs space that is at
least into the date
this finishes the proof and also
finishes the dot thank you